opencourseware is a web-based program
that will provide free access to primary
materials for virtually every course at
mit the founders of ocw had a
transformative vision 20 years ago of
offering access
to
materials from the mit classroom openly
freely
they can learn from them straight off
the website they can download them and
carry them around they can remix them
with other kinds of materials and mash
them up in new ways they can share them
with their networks
we're getting about 22 million visits
per year we have more than 3 million
subscribers to the ocw youtube channel
it makes it the
biggest.edu youtube channel in the world
it has captured
curious learners of all stripes from
around the world
several thousand mit faculty have shared
materials from more than 2 500 courses
we're sharing materials not just from
the science technology engineering and
math courses and the management courses
that mit is most famous for but also
from the incredible richness of our
humanities and social sciences
the impact of ocw and opening learning
for millions around the world is
multiplied by the role of educators
elsewhere when they take materials from
ocw and repurpose them and use them and
make them part of their own teaching for
each one educator that does that there's
dozens or hundreds more people for whom
the opportunities to learn are opened up
it takes resources to do what we do at
opencourseware takes a lot of people and
time and energy and money
to cover the full curriculum at mit we
are right in the middle of building the
next generation platform for ocw expect
to roll it out within a few months
it will be mobile friendly it will have
much better search tools
what we teach at mit changes with time
how we teach changes with time we need a
new platform that will allow us to keep
the content and ocw current and vibrant
now it should be free and especially
knowledge that comes from leading
institutions institutions with the most
privilege behind them to give that back
to the world has never been more
important than it is today
so many of the challenges that the world
is facing require the development the
application the testing the refinement
of new forms of knowledge
we firmly believe that a world in which
the educational attainment of millions
of people has been elevated will be a
better world this
is making a difference
[Music]
you